hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work okay before I do anything someone
told me this look at the garden on the
windows somewhere there's some sort of
eyeballs in the forest over here that
I'm supposed to see you now no see any
well oh it's a [ __ ] shovel
I actually startled me ok so I'm
supposed to seize that I don't know what
they're talking about I don't know what
they're talking about they ain't talking
about nothing
there ain't nothing ok but there was
something that someone said buying the
by the Fed fine the ha ha ha late that
handy look at that
picked up the West Wing key so let's get
the fudge out of here I don't know I
really don't know what they were talking
about about the whole eyeballs in the
forest thing cuz I don't see anything
I really don't am I supposed ooh okay
alright whatever I'm out of here
let's get back into the West Wing
The Shard now shined with a beautiful
but dangerous scarlet coloured energy
moly aim gingerly lifted it with a pair
of forceps he had to be extremely
careful not to touch a shard with his
skin lest he risk it fusing with him
rather than his subject
oh it fused with me does I mean I'm
turning into a monster of sorts probably
cuz your ass yeah
[Music]
uh-huh yeah right okay all right
also he turns into a giant monster or
something by Wes Twinkie what what's
happening they I'm turning into a
monster
all right
[Music]
okay
no monsters something's happening
something happening here what why Tom
Ward ah hell whoa
hey buddy anybody in here the nope
happening that is not happening
what the hell how do ya think Oh give me
the heebie-jeebies like I never had
before
oh god oh god oh I know what it was it
was the baby face on the fountain but it
was just falling in the middle still
there okay oh god he was like oh god oh
man
oh I'm not even exaggerating that's all
we're good
Oh Oh do not like that Oh God give me
the heebie-jeebies heebie-jeebies so bad
the heebie do with oh man what is
happening here I'm losing my mind I'm
losing my mind I'm losing my mind
what is this that's a ton that's a tiny
desk what wait a minute they work they
don't work
hey how cool is that is there a tiny
bottle of oil what the [ __ ] is so weird
is so weird tiny bottle of oil but it
works York's oil works
houki okay that's normal
yeah holy crap this is so weird
this is so weird it's all weird
Oh flat bottle a peripatetic
man this is some of the coolest stuff
I've ever seen in a Mischa brother cool
stuff I've seen in any game wah dah huh
jumping puzzle ha ha jumping puzzle
seriously this has got to be the coolest
ever
oh man but that damn baby that damn baby
face creep he'll watch out of me all
right oh hello that's been bricked up
that door still open there appears to be
a shard it's floating in the breeze hand
let me sorry let me get it I'll hit me
then poof that ball
ah I got the West Wing key hey it worked
whoa I can't move what the hell what
what was that wait a minute what hang on
I gotta see this I'm out in the front
area huh alright then I won't go that
way spork
uh oh no what was going on there it's
like I saw duplicates of it I don't know
at first he felt nothing perhaps only
settled tounging sensation toward the
card that came to pain and not physical
but psychological as his mind went in to
he saw nothing but chaos you fell
different colder crueler harder faster
better stronger so you
nothing and I fell over
Charles fall down Charles go boom
oh boy what da hell there's that not
right wait a minute this is the buzzer
you can't get me in here I'm too safe
from you huh
how are you gonna get me I'm freakin
upside down you can't even walk through
the doorway oh thank you
actually is stuff in here what's in here
why is gravity not work
gravity is not working correctly this
should not be happening give me a chair
thank you please thank you give me
please I have urgent business to attend
to with the door I'm going to break the
fudge down ah huh get me out of here get
out here thank you
oh boy this is not normal house layout
maybe this is how monsters just see the
world I don't know
you give me that chair I need this chair
come on about down sharp okay just a
lecture I need you thank you
oh lordy Lou okay wait a minute
isn't this just the UM isn't this just
the other wing is just the other wing
right this is just the east wing except
now it's upside down right oh yeah I got
a barrel can I get in you maybe might
need more than just this barrel I can't
even get on the barrel doesn't look like
it has anything important so I'll hold
off till later Barrow you're coming with
me they're gonna be my first and last
line of defense on the monstrosity that
is in this part ah piss oh no no piss
yes piss now pass I don't think I can
get through there oh yeah maybe I can't
my hang on seems to be a pass come on
I'm like so close okay okay I have what
I keep getting stuck I just need to get
more stuff out of this room till I can
go into that room boxes come here come
here come here
you're coming with me I need you the
whole world is got flipped turned upside
down so why don't you just come with me
and share right there tell you how are
you gonna shut the [ __ ] up no singing in
here
okay I'm gonna run out of oil maybe I
should try to go into that room before I
go in here probably a good idea cuz this
seems like an impossible area for these
boxes okay I'm gonna okay come on come
on I'm going to run out of oil here and
it's going to get dark I do not want to
be here and the dark I'm calm IANA comma
comma comma comma comma comma comma
thank you thank you thank you
oh fudge I need the barrel girl come
here come here come here come here come
here come here come here
thank you turning out the light
okay okay you're gonna stay up there yes
no it's really friggin dark why are you
not turning the correct way please don't
thank you to hop and hop in the hoop and
ah haha oh oh no how about gonna get out
of here
Oh piss I want supposed to come in here
vaj piss piss and vinegar
Bob Pass husband yeah maybe I give these
boxes ah ha ha ha ha huh
get down get box you son of a [ __ ] get
down
oh [ __ ] I shouldn't have come in here
there's a key I know I see a key hang on
I see a key I was supposed to come in
here but there's this other douchebag of
a box I won't get down so I got to go up
and get it hang on hang on a second here
ok oh ok here to die there we go
and I'm almost here with this and this
and I can probably just jump up with two
I probably didn't even need the third
one ha
no I didn't want to like that basement
key just on the best okay so nothing in
here that I need [ __ ] there we go nope
da by the looks of it I'm all out of oil
but that doesn't matter
I'm getting the hell out of here but
it's dark outside ooh I don't care I'm
just getting the hell out of here [ __ ]
these guys do not want to stack
correctly why would you stack in a
diagonal when you have the perfectly
good option of stacking completely flat
like just saying just throwing that out
there as a suggestion for your future
box-like endeavors
I'll grab I can't grab one of you I'm
out a while oh I can't see a bloody
fleeting thing I'm like totally in the
blackness just like my soul blackness
nothing but darkness come here you
thought you could get away from me I
know you guys can't see anything in God
turn up the gamma hip that's a little
better
not that oil did not last there's one
thing about this custom story that don't
change the pace
the oil haha because I'm pretty
conservative when it comes to my oil
usage and yet here I be with no oil to
my name get through there I don't even
think I'm supposed to do that how the
hell I even know I don't even know I
can't even get these things through here
oh there we go oh never mind I can it's
just hard that's what she said y'all
okay shut up
box please turn correctly no that is
wrong that way oh yeah why are you going
there's a right way in a wrong way
box you're gonna be absolute wrong this
way oh I can't even get through here
this is bull how am I split to get over
there how am I supposed to do this
hammer chipper no object to use done
nope no object easy I have the beige
Ricky and I see a basement door over
there maybe maybe it's not the basement
door maybe I'm wrong maybe I just need
to go higher higher you heard me hah
okay let's try this again higher nope
it's a completely roof to ceiling
impassable wall so I don't know what I'm
supposed to do here what maybe I'm just
supposed to go back and probably it
probably oh lordy oh oh this is gonna be
problematic isn't it I'm not gonna be
able ha there we go I just need the box
that one box in this barrel I'm not
gonna drag all their other ones over
there Jesus Cristo
ah once again they get me stuck on these
puzzles in it kind of I was kind of get
you know I kind of get into the
atmosphere I'm totally all about it and
then they get me stuck on these puzzles
and I'm just wandering around for a
while doing nothing and it kind of
breaks it all so that's unfortunate
that's one thing that I wish that I
could change with this games [ __ ] and
he'll just get fine do that is that
enough
no it's not cuz you're an a-hole you're
an a-hole
I even know if I'm supposed to go back
Oh piss
oh don't be Oh what up boy where did you
go where'd you go which go I don't even
know I don't care anymore I don't care
rabble rabble rabble rabble rabble
rabble just be like that I hope I didn't
need all three boxes cuz I'll just be
silliness okay now I'm through again I
got the base Mickey Peppa oh [ __ ] me
where's the basement doors that is the
basement door I just don't have a [ __ ]
okay come with I'm gonna [ __ ] them all
out of time I've been ah passing vinegar
show me Maloney what the hell what wait
a minute that's not right hang on wait
I'm not gonna in this and I'm not gonna
enter just yet cuz something just
happened here I think that was supposed
to happen haha what I don't even what
what the hell just happened it just
exploded it's wrong okay good yeah
there's still an invisible wall here
that was not supposed to happen and I'm
stuck I broke the game again and I've
lost another box [ __ ] I keep losing
everything
Oh keep losing Wow what why I still
can't see it a blatant bloody damn
bloody pleading bloody thing oh man
everything keeps going black why oh man
ha better oh I'm gonna kill someone
oh [ __ ] and how oh [ __ ] it I give up you
guys tell me what to do because this is
[ __ ] ha oh man this guest second
game it's gonna make me bipolar
I'll go ha ha man is so cool I love it
ah [ __ ] my life you know I go back and
forth between then that God
dick punching party is back on cuz [ __ ]
alright so tell me what to do like I'm 7
or 2 or whatever age you want to put me
tell me what to do huh thank you so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]
I'm literally standing on top of the
white